[Music]
have you ever wondered how banks are
keeping your money safe and how banks
monitor their credit risk before our
presentation we will show you a short
animation outlining the business problem
the solution and how technology can help
meet Charles meet Charles a credit risk
manager at a bank on a daily basis
Charles is responsible for monitoring
the risks related to lending its money
to other companies the problem nowadays
isn't getting information but getting
the right information the big data world
is Charles's struggle it's impossible to
read all the news about these companies
and often it comes in a language that
Charles doesn't speak and even if most
is just noise sometimes there are really
relevant and even urgent things
mentioned in local news wouldn't it be
great to help Charles do his job even
better and stay on top of the credit
risks the bank is facing for that we
created early warning system a machine
learning based application that is
trained to process all the data that
becomes available with early warning
system Charles gets proactive signals
about his counterparties but he needs to
look at on the devices he has these
signals come from all the local markets
where his clients are active in all
different languages early warning system
translates everything into English so
that Charles understands
this saves him lots of time and makes
his life in the big data world much
better early warning system good
afternoon my name is Otto fern and I am
a technology partner at PwC I'm very
pleased to be here at cloud next 18 what
we've seen is that the main business
challenge for Charles is getting the
right information at the right time and
that his problem could be solved if he
gets information from around the globe
at the right time so that's why we built
an early warning system for credit risk
management extracting insight from
public data public data from around the
globe which enables to carry risk
managers to focus on important events
and also supports their decision-making
and how and why is that possible now it
is possible because we have nearly
unlimited compute power and storage
capacity from the cloud we have a whole
range of api's and algorithms for
machine learning and also because we now
work agile and abling fast
experimentation so that enabled us to
build a proof-of-concept in 12 weeks
time I will now walk you briefly through
the agenda first I introduced the team
and explain how we did come together
after that ing will explain why this use
case for credit risk management is so
important to them then we will elaborate
on our approach of this proof of concept
and design of it and after that we will
explain the technical solution including
a technical demo then we'll wrap up with
the key takeaways of this project as you
can see we are here with three main
parties they are ing Google and PUC and
how did we come together
well easy Google approaches and
indicated that ing had the idea to
collect real-time news and perform
corresponding analysis for the credit
risk management department and they
asked whether we would be
willing to work with them which of
course we would so we quickly built a
demo and the demo convinced ing that
they were on the right track and needed
to explore this further so they asked us
to build this proof of concept before I
now hand over to the next speaker I will
introduce the team first of all we have
announced at our Anant is the executive
owner of this project and the head of
portfolio management at orangey is also
the father of this project in a
non-steam where the executive sponsors
five core team members and over 30 test
users then from PVC we have apart from
myself Peter for hire
Peter is the engagement leader of this
project and leads or banking innovation
practice in consulting Peter will be
followed by beta beta where hers is a
cloud native architect and a technical
lead and his hobby is kubernetes and
you'll hear a lot more about that later
also in our team data scientists a UX
designer and a front-end developer and
then not on the presentation but equally
important Petrus Rihanna fish from
Google she is the account man from IMG
and has given us tremendous insights and
access to the right experts within
Google so now you've seen the animation
we've had an introduction to the project
and the team and it's time to hand over
to unmount ATAR and on off to you
thank you all as also mentions you could
see me as the father of this project and
I'm quite proud of it where we are now I
started with early warning systems about
a few years ago now and we as I and G
are quite excited to be able to share
with you what you can do with today's
technology we developed this tool within
the whole cell credit risk management
space which means that we focus on
clients such as large corporates
financial institutions like banks
insurance companies and countries what
personally makes this project really
interesting for me is the fact that it
actually shows that also in the risk
management space we're innovating as
well and in line with ing strategy we're
trying to stay a step ahead as you could
see in the introduction movie we have to
deal with a lot of information these
days and what I will try to do is
actually explain why we started this
with all this information overload that
we have today to do so I will first
start to explain to you what credit risk
management is and then I will actually
guide you through an example using the
workday of a credit risk manager
so let's start with what is credit risk
management to answer that question I'll
actually go back to the basics of
banking if you look at banks banks are a
place where you go to to deposit your
money to borrow money or to transfer
money from one place to the other end in
essence we're just financial as
financial services company so if you as
an individual deposit your money with a
bank the bank will actually land that
money to a client who is in need of
money and when we do that we actually
run a risk and that risk is called
credit risk it's the risk that when we
lend out money to a client we run the
risk that the client will not be able to
repay that money in other words they
won't be able to add her to the
obligation towards the bank if you look
very closely to this picture you will
actually see that you as a private
private individual are also running a
risk but then on the bank and as a
result of that we are a regulated entity
so we need to apply to a lot of rules
and regulations just to make sure that
your money is safe with us and within
this whole scheme having proper early
warning systems are quite important so
now looks let's look at what happens
when we actually lend out money what
we'll do to assess the risk we'll do a
lot of analysis we'll look at the
financial health of a company we'll look
at the management team of the company
where they're able to actually add her
to the strategy that have set out we'll
look at micro economic type of events
we'll look at the balance sheet the net
profitability of the company and so
forth and what we'll do is
actually we input all these variables
into what we call a credit risk model
these are models that we've internally
developed which have also been validated
by independent parties within the bank
and offer way by the regulator so when
we input all these variables we get a
risk rating and a risk rating is nothing
more than an output of model and it
classified it gives you the
classification of the risk so with an ID
we use a number code one being very good
risk
whilst eighteen being very bad risk
external rating agencies actually do the
same thing they use Triple A for very
low risk will strip will be and Beyond
is very high risk so when we've engaged
with a client and we've determined
actually that we're willing to run the
risk and because it's within our risk
appetite what we'll do is we'll start
monitoring that client which means that
we're actually starting to see whether
there are any signals out there which
actually causes any potential issues
that we would have with the client going
forward this is what we call early
warning signals and then on daily basis
what we'll do is we'll use sources like
news market prices but also like interim
figures I can give you a lot of examples
of early warning signals but these are
quite different for type of clients and
perkupp refer type of industry so what
I'll do is I'll just run you through the
day of a risk manager
so let's meet Charles actually it's
almost the same guy as in the
introduction movie but but then with a
different hair color well Charles is a
is a credit risk manager who has a
portfolio of 100 clients which are
globally active he has been with the
bank for about like ten years
he's very seasoned banker so he actually
has developed a sixth sense which
actually tells him when he's looking at
a transaction whether it's a good or bad
risk and in line with all credit risk
managers who are out there we don't like
any type of surprises so let's look at
Charles day first of all he gets into
the office his office he grabs a cup of
coffee and then goes through his pace
basically he looks at the risks I mean
the the news which is relevant for his
portfolio and then he also runs through
all the transaction so he looks at
transactions where he that he needs to
prove I already you will decline them he
looks at annual reviews and he also
looks at rating models so Charles has
quite a busy day and in that day he also
needs to make sure that it captures all
these signals in information out there
for his hundred clients now let's
imagine the following one day Charles is
actually reading the newspaper
a global newspaper he finds out that one
of his client is involved in a bribery
case in a very specific country
[Music]
which surprises him because he didn't
know about them so being a risk manager
he starts digging in deeper and then he
finds out that actually this information
was already available a month ago but
only in that very specific country and
in a very specific language digging
deeper he actually finds out that the
stock price has been declining for like
a month for 10% and they didn't know
about that as you can imagine Charles
being a person who isn't fond of
surprises
he's quite upset now let's look at
another example meet Lauren Lauren is
also a credit risk manager but then for
banks and for countries and her
portfolio is actually much more geared
toward market based type of prices okay
thanks I hope you can hear me now okay
well actually what it means is that
Lauren has to look whether the whether
the risk rating profile of that client
needs to be just an announcer but one
day she finds well actually she finds
out that the news was already available
a day ago when the external rating
agencies downgraded the country like
Charles she's not really happy so what
do Lauren and Charles have in common
well basically they have to deal with a
lot of information we'll say they have
rules they have to do their regular day
job imagine that you have to look you
have like 2,000 counterparties across
the globe in 75 languages with more than
20,000 sources that you need that you
get information from that's a lot so
they run the risk of losing out on early
warning signals so we identified this
problem within the wholesale risk
management space and we wanted to have a
tool which actually gives us information
which a big coverage a news market data
which is relevant for the risk manager
so we can actually move faster and
catching these signals and much much be
more proactive as a risk management
departments and moving toward what we
call a continuous monitoring framework
so the tool that has been built now is
actually a first step
it has global and local new sentiments
it has market prices such as equity CD s
commodity prices and for cont for
countries organizations and sectors
users can actually set their own
threshold levels and when something is
reached the the tool will actually
signal or give a notification to the
user for us this is a first step because
we always anticipate it when we started
with this project that we want to have a
tool which is much more predictive
remember the sixth sense that I talked
about with Charles well Charles this
this sixth sense is nothing more than a
heuristic that he develop across the
years and we believe that with the
current data that which is available but
also with the existing and future
machine learning technology which is out
there we can make a tool that is much
more predictive so why did we build it
from scratch well we as ing where we're
data company and we we think that it has
a lot of advantages to build these type
of applications yourself first of all in
today's world is run relatively easy in
and you can build these tools quite
quickly for a very specific use case
second of all it gives you a lot of
flexibility it makes you also
independent from other solution
providers which actually provide a lot
of features that you often don't need
besides the fact that we design do you
want to be masters of our own destiny
we've actually proven that we can we can
build these types of tools ourselves so
that's why we actually partner up with
Google and PwC to build this tool we're
at the stage now that where we have
tested the tool across eight countries
with 30 users and we're now determining
the next steps in developing the tool
further
but more importantly to embed it in our
core monitoring processes going forward
so I hope now you get a better feeling
why we need to have the tool but also
that credit risk management is a very
data-driven and also a very analytical
function within the bank well with that
I want to thank you for your attention
sorry about that thank you for your
attention and hand it back to Otto thank
you announce that was very clear I think
we now know what a bank does and that
credit risk management is extremely
important to them also good to hear that
the proof of concept addressed your
early warning signal challenges and also
that you are looking forward to use
machine learning to get more predictive
signals so now I think it's time that we
hear about project has evolved and what
the design principles fair so over to
Peter for hi it's great to be here and
talk to you about our proof of concept
personally I'm very passionate about
solving important problems and making
innovation really happen and I will in
my part run you through the approach
that we applied this proof of concept
secondly the design of the solution and
the underlying business needs and
thirdly I will give you a demo of the
solution itself we start with the first
part the approach for me there are three
crucial ingredients that have been part
of this proof concept the first is the
team you need to have the right skills
and people to deliver fast in our case
we created five skill sets an IT
architect a user experience designer the
user interface developer to implement
the design data scientists to build
models to detect early warning signals
and credit risk expertise from
and his team to tell us actually what is
relevant to see my lesson learned from
building such a team is that you need to
find the right balance the balance of
experts who can deliver very fast in
their area of expertise but also skill
overlaps so that you built in the end
the solution that fits together the
second ingredient was the way of working
we really were benefiting from direct
user feedback all the time we applied an
agile way of working and we started with
a demo that was only built in two weeks
time shown to the end-users and based on
that approach we got a very valuable
feedback and a dialogue that it could
build upon for the rest of the project
we took that feedback into our backlog
started planning the first sprint and
from that moment on the rhythm was there
that we could work with the end users
continuously the third ingredient was
scoping we only were using public data
in the beginning and that increased
speed tremendously we didn't need to
connect with any other existing IT
system within the bank at that point in
time and that was very important for us
now the approach that we applied had
three phases on a high level the first
phase was really the beginning when we
needed to start from scratch nothing
there on the Google cloud platform
environment just the project name then
we started with the three ingredients
that I just explained and with the
services available in the Google cloud
platform to develop the solution in
sprints and I think the success factor
was that we had a successful demo every
sprint and at the end of six prints a
working proof-of-concept ready for user
testing at that time in our case this
for me really demonstrated the power
that you get from building proof
concepts with the Google Cloud it you
can really go fast with your proof
concepts in our case it was a successful
proof of concept so we decided to move
on and the second
face was about testing it with users as
Anand explained eight locations around
30 users and through those user pilots
we gathered a lot of feedback and data
that we could use to retrain the models
for machine learning perspective and
decide what is actually relevant to see
for users and now we are in the third
phase where we are deciding how to roll
this out further and take this into
production into the core processes of
the bank now that was the approach on
how we did this proof of concept now
quickly I would want to take you through
what we exactly built this is a very
simplistic representation of our
solution on the bottom you see two types
of data sources that we ingest firstly
market data in terms of equity prices
credit default swaps bonds and other
financial instruments coming from
Thomson Reuters based on the license
that ID has with them secondly news
coming from public sources via Google G
delt and others that's something we
uploaded into the Google cloud platform
ingest it and there we have built a
pipeline to process and analyze that
information in that middle layers also
where the machine learning is happening
and then based on that pipeline we
decide what to display to a user who's
able to log into an interface and from
there get that information to him on the
right side you see some statistics of
what we are actually processing the
current scope is around 250 clients or
organizations in the tool and you can
get an impression of the amount of
information that we are processing on a
daily basis now that was a very
simplistic picture and actually through
those prints we encountered some very
specific business needs that we needed
to fulfill and overcome to build a
successful proof-of-concept five are
here on the screen you need to have
maximum coverage deliver the signals and
real time with enriched information so
that you're sure that the imputation is
right filtered and ranked based on
relevance and then in the end clustered
into single events and I will go through
each of those in more detail in the
coming slides the first part is coverage
we really learned that entity profiles
derive the coverage that we were looking
for in one of the first demos we
actually got the feedback that we were
missing out on important information and
as an aunt explained you don't want to
miss out on those
signals the reason for missing out an
information was that we were only
looking for information with the parent
company name and actually we learned
that we should take a different approach
we should build entity profiles with all
the aliases subsidiaries underneath that
company in different languages as you
can see here as an example for ING and
in that way we have been able to
increase the coverage with the factor
five to ten on average for each client
now the information is done coming in
and you want to process that in real
time that's a key requirement for risk
managers so that he gets those signals
fast and can respond to them as you see
here for an average risk manager with a
portfolio of 50 clients that's quite a
lot of information that we need to
handle on a daily basis she talked about
15,000 news items 250 financial
instruments which are continuously
moving and that's all something we need
to be able to process in real time so
how can we help the risk manager to stay
in stop of these things in the technical
part done by pater we will talk about
the architecture and the way we
developed a solution to make this to
meet this requirement the third one is
enrichment so as a risk manager you
actually want to have information that
is truly about the organization that you
are responsible for so you need to be
able to cut out the false positives as
the example here shows you if you get a
average
news item you see a lot of actors
mentioned in the news item if you would
do a keyword search any of for any of
the organizations this item would pop up
but if you are looking for early warning
signals only in the case of oil company
e this is a true positive early warning
signal so the rest are just false
positive and you'd want to filter those
out so you need to go beyond the keyword
method and applying techniques to
understand who what when and where this
event actually is happening and we use
the natural language processing
technique for that we show later on how
that works the fourth part is now we
went very broad a lot of information is
coming in we also enrich that so it's
really about this counterparty or client
but now there's still too much
information to handle so you need to be
able to filter that information and
select items which are actually relevant
for a credit-based manager to take a
look at as you can see here they're also
some examples of things you don't want
to take a look at as a risk manager so
if you are responsible for monitoring a
bank and you get in the Global News you
also see a lot of local news about ATM
incidents for instance negative
sentiment but not relevant for credit
risk manager on that level same with car
manufactures you get in news about car
accidents as well so what we need to do
is actually make that distinction in in
our pipeline to detect what type of
topics are relevant for a craftsman
credit based manager to take a look out
look at and cut out the other part which
is just noise frame and then the fourth
or sorry the fifth one is the clustering
so now we have relevant items to take a
look at but as you can imagine if such
an event happens more publishers are
writing about it and it becomes a very
annoying experience for user that you
get that same news message over and over
again but then from a different news
publisher so what you need to do to
solve this is build a clustering
algorithm that
understands that actually based on the
text this is talking about the same
event and that's what we did so that you
cluster it into a single event and bring
that message only once to the user now
these are the five building blocks of
our solution the last thing I would like
to do is take you through a demo of what
the solution now really looks like for
the purpose of the demo we don't want to
harm anyone here in the room with
showing real early warning signals so we
created a simulated data set with domain
names and dummy news items the rest of
the tool is working just as it is now
Charles was logging in as you can see
nothing there yet on his homepage so the
first thing he does is he goes to his
portfolio and he wants to add
counterparties to his organization a
list but you can also start searching
for names so that's what he's doing
right now and he adds a second
organization to his portfolio third one
and the fourth or ghen ization so now he
has four organizations in his portfolio
yes there they are
and then he will click top left going
back to the home page and on the left of
side of the screen you see the news feed
and the news feed has factors like
sentiment score dates entities found you
can also filter on the time period you
can filter the news on various factors
like relevance or sentiment negative or
popularity which means you know how much
is written about it and then here you
see that he goes to a specific article
which has five similar items that's the
clustering so these are all about the
same event in different languages with
different titles so this is I think
Chinese a French article FR is french
translated and then clustered into that
single event on the right side you see
the market information so equity prices
so the first one is a negative one
so it went down so he takes a look at
this specific counterparty page with
much more detailed information I could
do price credit default swap credit
ratings but actually this is all very
reactive thing you need to go and look
for the information but what you can do
as well is there set your triggers and
make it proactive so let's say the
equity price drops 5% in a day that's
what he's doing now he adds that to his
portfolio you can do the same thing with
for instace keywords in case of fraud
for instance if there's a news item with
fraud in it I want to note be notified
immediately and that's what the trigger
is doing so it's already running now in
the background and checking if there are
any of those triggers been hit new
sentiment very negative not a trigger
credit ratings if there's a probably
downgrade that's something you want to
be notified of immediately and in this
way it becomes a very proactive way of
getting that information because now
those triggers will search for you and
make sure that that information is
coming to you there's already one been
hit now around fraud so there has been
an article about fraud on a specific
client take a look yes there it is
and now sentiment score of minus 70 so
it's relatively high and now the user is
giving you feedback on the specific item
I'd like to see more about that or for
instance the second one he doesn't
consider relevant so that's information
we can use to actually make those models
that we have running in the background
more advanced with machine learning so
that was a very short demo but I hope it
demonstrated to you that we have been
able to actually create a digital
assistant for a credit vest manager to
make his job much more easy with
increased coverage increased response
time and in the end a proactive tool
that makes the sure that the information
comes to him at the right time with that
I would like to thank you and
and back to although so thank you Peter
for explaining the way how we approach
projects you did that very well and also
thank you for outlining the business
concepts which we needed I think it's
now more than time that we dive into
some of the technical details of this
project to show some technical me to the
bone and like to have some stage better
mirrors
so my name is pedro vickers i'm the
cloud architect and one of the software
developers of this tool and i would like
this i would like to make this
presentation a bit more technical so i'm
really excited to do that i hope you are
too
so let's start with a schematic overview
okay it's already switch in chemistry
can you switch back please to the slide
yeah thank you so what you see here is a
schematic overview of the solution we
built in the Google cloud as you can see
we use a lot of managed Google cloud
services which really allowed us to
develop quickly on the left side you see
the the input we use for the pipeline
you see on the right side so the input
consists of the entity profiler and
consists of public data sources the news
so on the right side we have the the
pipeline we built and as you can see it
consists mainly of two very important
components one of them is Google cloud
pub/sub and one of them is google
kubernetes engine this combination made
sure that this pipeline is really robust
but still very flexible and I will show
you why later in the demo these this
pipeline it separated into a couple of
steps and every step every step is his
own kubernetes deployment so we can
easily scale it independently from the
other kubernetes deployments and all
deployments communicate via pub/sub so
the input comes from pops up and the
output goes to pops up until processing
an article is finished so what I want to
do now is switch to the demo please I
want to show you I want to take you on a
trip on trip of an article through the
pipeline and we'll do this in a Jupiter
notebook I hope you can read it from the
back and what we will do is we will
start with building an entity profile in
this case we will just use PwC
it's the only keyword we use as an input
and we only build a part of the entity
profile which is gathering the aliases
and Wikipedia pages of this entity so we
will run this and as you can see we find
quite some aliasing subsidiaries in
different languages different character
sets different namings and we use all
these aliases to search for news about
this company what you also see is a
couple of wikipedia identifiers and
these are really important for us in a
later stage so what would you now is
we'll use one of the aliases in this
case number 5 which is just PwC and what
we do is we generate RSS feed URLs to
the Google News so as you can see we use
the word as a as a query for this RSS
feed and what you also see is we query
for specific additions and in addition
on Google News is a combination of a
language and a country so in this case
it would be a French article written in
Belgium for this example we will query
one Google News or RSS feed and we only
use one edition Dutch Edition so what we
will do is we parse the feed we get the
feed in and you what you see here is the
first five articles of this RSS feed
it's in Dutch so probably you won't be
able to understand it but that will that
will come later
what we get from the RSS feed here is
the headline is the publish date and the
URL to the original article
so this is the first part where where
pops up comes in because before this we
have to we have to start with a pipeline
at a moment where we start with the cure
and then what cure does it was located
on the previous slide what a cure does
is it published it periodically
publishes a task - pops up where it says
hey can you query on PwC on the Dutch
Edition on Google News so that's done
now and what we now do is for every
article we get from this RSS feed we
publish a task - pops up saying hey can
you process this article for me and we
have different workers which listen to
this pub subtopic get the task and
process it so it's as easy as this just
I publish to a specific topic and
subscribe to a specific subscription
within that topic what I want to show
you now is some statistics so we'll open
this one what you see here is some
metrics from pops up in the first chart
you see how many messages we publish -
pops up in this case it's about almost I
think 2000 per second at one point and
we do it for I think a couple of minutes
which leads to a total Q in pops up a
flow of articles to process of 200,000
articles can be duplicates so here you
see the entire queue and what you here
see is the amount of articles the pros
the the workers process so it's about I
think 30,000 per this is five minutes so
in like 30 minutes we process the entire
queue and then we just wait for we
search again on those entities and this
is an this is a graph showing the age of
the oldest tasks in this pub sub Q so
which is about 2600 seconds I know it's
I think it's 40 minutes
and what makes this setup really nice is
that we can skill the workers
independently so let's say you think
this is too long I don't want to wait 40
minutes if something happens I want to
know I want to know it quicker then we
can say okay let's kill the workers
independently and let's kill them too
for example the double amount of workers
and then this number this 30,000 will
increase to 60,000 60,000 and your queue
will be processed in half the time so I
would like to show how easy this is
first I'd like to know how many of you
have hands-on experience with kubernetes
okay that's nice it's quite some you
probably know how to scale a cube lens
deployment for the people who don't I
would like to show you how easy it is so
let me zoom in a little what we do here
is we see these are the workers that
process that the first part of an
article you see I think it's 12
containers or twelve pots so what we
want to do is we want to scale this so
we are not happy with this
30 minutes processing time so what we
will do is there so here it says we want
to run 12 replicas so what if we let's
say we change to 18 so we want 50% more
50% more pods running then you
immediately see that now kubernetes
spawns up sponsored more containers and
they are running already now and they
listen to the same pub sub topic so pops
up make sure the ddd tasks are
distributed over these containers so if
we now would wait for I think a couple
of minutes and the pipeline would start
again this bar would be at like 45
thousands per 5 minutes so it's that
easy to scale this
so let's assume that article arrived at
the processor then we instantiate a new
article and we have the same information
that was in the RSS feed so the
information was sent to pops up and we
get this information from pops up so
nothing added here just the URL we have
the original headline in the original
language and the publish date what we do
now is we give the the work at the task
to visit the website and collect collect
the body from the website so what you
here see is the body of the article it's
in Dutch and we need this for further
processing what were you after this is
of course we translate the article
because we only process I think 75
languages and we all need it in English
so we use the Google Cloud Translate API
to translate the headline and the body
of the article so now you know what this
article is about it says Alfa Hills is
the new CEO of BW Netherlands and we
have to translate a body here now we
have the article in English we can use
it for the Google cloud natural language
processing API and this API does three
things for us first of all we want to
analyze the sentiment of the article so
a credit risk manager is is really
interested in mainly negative news so a
negative sentiment is more important for
a credit course manager than a positive
sentiment so we'll just analyze the
sentiment and here it says okay we have
a sentiment score which is normally
between minus 1 which is very negative
and one which is very positive of 26
0.26 it was quite positive and here we
have a magnitude and the magnitude is a
is a number that represents the number
of expresses of emotions used in this
text is three point three the second
thing we do with NLP is we analyze
entities and this is really an important
part
for us because we want to extract the
entities and we know want to know which
and this is the article about so let's
run it well here you see it extracted
auto fills as a person and it also
extracted PwC Netherlands as an
organisation and here you see why the
Wikipedia is so important for us because
what we had what we had we just search
for PwC and when we search for PwC we
don't know if if the results are about
the PwC we are looking at but we know
that when an RP processed it and says
hey this is the Wikipedia of this
company and then we know we have this
Wikipedia in our database now we can
make the match this is really the
company we are interested in and I saw
this example let me go a bit up here it
says water polo association PwC which is
completely different entity we have a
textual match but probably if we if we
would pass this through NOP it would not
recognize this entity as being
PricewaterhouseCoopers that's really
important what you also see here is the
salience and the salience is a very
important number and it represents the
importance of an entity within this
article so it's ordered by salience so
it says all fulfills is the most
important entity and next to that it's
PwC and here we can make a distinguish
between is this is this article really
about this entity or did we just find it
somewhere in your article we also have a
sentiment per entity where we have the
same thing like score and magnitude so
we know if an article is negative we
want to know okay it's a really negative
about identity or maybe about another
entity we have a couple of more entities
we only have the the proper type
entities in here so not all entities
found and what you here C is also type
event and this is really important for
clustering later so it recognizes a
couple of events so it was about alpha
hills being appoints its new CEO and we
have appointment as an event here
the last thing an Opie does for us is
analyze the category of the article so
Google configured a couple of hundred
categories and they have this NLP
functionality where it can predict in
which category the article is so in the
case that for example PwC would sponsor
a sports event the article will be pro
the article would be would probably be
classified as a sports and that's a
category we are not interested in so we
can we only use white listed categories
like these business and industrial or
company news and here it says is it's 90
percent sure that this article belongs
to the category business and industrial
so now we can continue with processing
this article but because these these
couple of hundred categories are still
quite general and not based or not
specified for the field of credit risk
we defined a couple of topics ourselves
and we create we trained a couple of
models that can classify the article for
these topics so we trained more than
these but a couple of a couple of models
with a scikit-learn and these are really
good at for example predicting if an
article is about fraud or about
bankruptcy it topics that are really
important for the accredited case
manager so here it says it's 11 percent
sure that it's about fraud a percent
sure about bankruptcy
now we created it we generate a summary
which is completely a newly generated
summary so we can show this in the
dashboards and after this we can remove
the original body and translate the body
because we don't need it anymore we
extracted all the information we need
from it and Malcolm here comes the last
part which is the clustering so what we
do with clustering is we create one big
matrix where all the columns are
entities we found in all articles we
found so there are hundreds of thousands
of columns in this matrix
maybe even millions I don't know and the
rows are individual articles and here
you see as a value the salience of that
entity in the specific article so for
this example we will find a related
article just as an example and we'll add
this to the matrix to show you how we do
this clustering so we found already
we found a related item about the C
point appointment and we added to the
matrix so what you can see is a couple
of entities are added here so these
entities are found in the second article
below but not in the first article and
also these entities are not found in the
first are found in the first article but
not in a second article and we can also
see that still alpha heels is the most
important entity in the first article
and the second article and what we can
do now is we calculate the cosine
similarity which is just a mathematical
formula which can calculate distance
between two vectors so this factor and
this factor and with this distance we
can say okay these two articles are
about the same event so let's calculate
it and error says okay I'm 82 percent
sure I with 82 percent match that these
for these two factors and we can play
with the threshold where we say okay if
we set the threshold at 80 percent then
these two articles would be closer
together if we would set the threshold
at 85 they wouldn't be closer together
so that was it that was it for the demo
now this I think cost me like 15 minutes
I think on a work it will take like 15
seconds and we do it a hundred thousand
times a day and what really helped us
here was the fact that we use kubernetes
engine amp up cept that we can scale now
we have 250 counterparties in the tool
it will be it will be increased to maybe
10 times this and I'm definitely I'm
confident that we can scale to that
amount of counterparties thank you
I think back to auto
[Applause]
Thank You Pater for this excellent demo
and I think now we all understand why
you're hobbyists er kubernetes I think
we've seen that we used a lot of the
components of GCP and also that it is
quite some coding ourselves so now I
think it's time to wrap up this session
and about to give you three key
takeaways the first is the right
information at the right time we have
seen that an international bank needs
information from around the globe at the
right moments but also that that
information is growing exponentially so
the key question was how to get the
right information at the right time at
the credit risk manager and I think that
vistas proof of concept we've shown that
you can do that the second key takeaway
is cloud and machine learning given what
we've seen in the past three to five
years ago it would have been
inconceivable to make this but now with
the advent of the cloud and also all
kinds of api's and algorithms for
machine learning like translation like
natural language processing developing a
system like this is quite easy
and finally agile working and fast
experimentation we have demonstrated
that is the right
tooling and the right team you can build
a prove a concept from scratch in just
12 weeks and you can do that as well and
start tomorrow since for time
[Applause]
[Music]